welcome everyone
and thank you for joining us for today's
keynote presentation titled
development of rational immunotherapy
combinations to overcome
the immunosuppressive prostate tumor
micro
environment we are delighted to bring
you this seminar presented by
lab roots my name is susie valdez and i
will be your moderator for today's
presentation
it's my pleasure to introduce you to our
speaker
dr sumit tsubudi an assistant professor
in the jenny tour urinary medical
oncology program at the university of
texas md anderson
cancer center for complete biography on
our speaker please visit the tab
on the top of your screen if you have
any questions during the presentation we
encourage you to submit it in the q
a box our speaker will address those
questions
following his presentation click on the
continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits if you would like to earn
an education and free continuing
education credits
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr sumit
tsubudi i will now turn the presentation
over to him
welcome sir
thank you susie and lab roots for uh
inviting me to
speak today and also to all the people
who have tuned in so early in the
morning especially those in the
west coast and so as susie said i'll be
talking about the immunosuppressive
prostate tumor microenvironment
here are my disclosures i want to point
out that i will be discussing non-fda
approved indications during this
presentation
so why immunotherapy it's because the
immune system
can actually kill tumor cells what you
see on the left
is a tumor cell surrounded by four t
cells
these t cells will serially attack the
cancer
so that eventually eradicates it that's
shown in the right
and the t-cells do this by taking
advantage of three specific properties
adaptability specificity and memory
this is important because especially the
memory
because this leads to durable or even
curative responses
now i'll keep coming back to this term
durable
responses in future slides
so tumor micro environment is quite
complex this is a simplification of the
immune portion of the tumor
microenvironment
and what you see in the center here is
the tumor cell
surrounded by a lot of immune cells on
the left and on the right
the key point of this figure is that
not all immune cells are good the ones
on the right are the ones that help the
tumor grow
and they're considered immunosuppressive
immune cells
and the ones on the left help
kill the cancer and these are called
immunostimulatory cells
examples of the ones on the right that
are immunosuppressive and help the
cancer grow
are immature dendritic cells macrophages
especially the m2 phenotype myeloid
derived suppressor cells
th2 cells as well as regulatory t
cells and they and a lot of the
cytokines associated with them
are il-6 or interleukin-6 interleukin-4
tgf-beta now for the immunostimulatory
which is on the left
examples include mature dendritic cells
cda t cells or cytotoxic t
cells natural killer cells and
cd4 t cells and cytokines associated
with them
are interleukin 2 interleukin-12
and interferon gamma now one of the
points of immunotherapies
is to switch to balance here within the
immune tumor microenvironment we want
less of the immunosuppressive cells and
more the immunostimulatory cells
so immunotherapies they come in many
flavors i'm just going to speak about a
few of them that are in clinic now
that have received fda approval
so vaccines these are therapies that
direct immune system to attack
and recognize a particular protein
on the cancer cell itself and those
proteins are called
tumor antigens
then you have cellular therapies there's
many examples but car t
cells is one of the hottest ones and
here
you have the the car t cells are
engineered
to directly recognize the cancer cells
and then finally you have immune
checkpoint therapies
that um or otherwise known as immune
checkpoint blockade
and this actually removes the breaks
from the t cells increases t cell
activation
and function
and one of the main points here is that
not all immunotherapies are same as you
can see that i've
given you three different examples with
different mechanisms of
action but they also have different side
effect profiles or toxicity profiles
for example vaccines are well known to
cause infusion related reactions as well
as flu-like symptoms
car t cells are known for decided
cytokine release syndrome or crs
and immune checkpoint therapies are
known for immune related adverse events
example or that are characterized by
inflammation
of various organ sites and
these this can be like uh similar to an
autoimmune phenomenon
now before i uh go on about imbue
checkpoint therapies i think it's
it's a good time to go back and really
understand how t cells are regulated
i'm going to go over two decades of work
by
jim allison in this one slide and so
jim allison in the early 1980s
discovered the t cell receptor or tcr
and that's expressed on the t cell and
it recognizes
the foreign proteins on another cell
and in this case it's recognizing a
tumor
antigen or a protein expressed under
tumor cells
and that tumor antigen is in the form of
a peptide that's complex with major
compatibility complex or mhc
and engagement of the t cell receptor
with the tumor antigen
causes the t cell to get stimulated
and it's a and it's what we call signal
one
but signal one alone does not cause
t cells to proliferate
the analogy that i would like to use is
what we do
when we start the car we put the key
into the car ignition and turn the
ignition
that would be signal one but as you know
the car
does not move you hear the motor but the
car does not move
in order to get the car to move you have
to press
or put your right foot on the gas pedal
and so when you do that the car moves
jim allison understood this and so he
searched for the second signal
and he found in the mid 1980s and that
the best characterized
coast inventory signal is cd28 or signal
2
and cd28 is constitutionally expressed
on t cells and it binds to its ligands
b71 or b72 they're also known as
cd80 and cd86 and they're expressed on
professional antigen presenting cells
such as dendritic cells
macrophages and b cells
now a key point here is signal 2 alone
is insufficient to get t cells to
proliferate
and signal 1 alone is insufficient to
get
t cells to proliferate similar to a car
analogy
without a key and you put your gas on
the gas pedal the car will not move
and without the and so you need both the
car key and the ignition as well as
the right foot on the gas pedal to get
things to move
but the problem is as the car is moving
at some point
you're gonna have to hit you need a
break and jim allison understood this
and in 1994 him and jeffrey bluestone
independently
discovered to break ctla4 now
break the break is crucial because think
about this
many of us when we get sick what we do
or we have a cough symptoms we start
feeling around our throat
because we're feeling for the lymph
nodes that are inflamed because the t
cells are fighting the infection
now if there was no break the t cells
would continue proliferating
and eventually we would die from a
lymphoproliferative disorder
and that's actually what happens in mice
that lack ctla4 or the brain
they die from a lymphoproliferative
disorder within two to three weeks of
being
born jim allison then
developed a drug that blocks the
function of c2a4 temporarily
and so it releases the brakes and allows
the t cells to
uh be functional again
and so he used this in a mouse model of
cancer and you can see that in the
control group the
without any treatment the tumors just
grow and so on the y-axis
is average tumor size on the x-axis is
days after tumor injection
in the bottom left you'll see three
arrows and those are the three
uh three time points in which anti-cla4
was administered
in the mice and you can see that in the
mice that received anti-seizing before
there was great reduction in
tumor growth rates
furthermore you see that the tumors
actually initially grew
but then shrunk and this is a phenomenon
that we call
pseudo progression and this is seen in
approximately
10 to 15 percent of our patients
here's an example of a patient who was
actually one of the earliest patients
treated with ipolium
and this is a patient with melanoma so
this patient unfortunately had exhausted
all
other therapies and was told his only
choices were a clinical trial
versus hospice care
after receiving one dose of ipalumab you
can see its cancer significantly
increased
on the left you can see it visually and
on the right you can see a cat scan
representing the cancer the patient was
told that he had progressed and would
need to go into hospice care
but while in hospice care you see that
the cancer actually shrunk
and eventually disappears so this is an
example of
pseudo-progression and that's seen again
in approximately 10 to 15 percent of our
patients
treated with it balloon mat so what's
actually going here why does it actually
increase in size
so if you took a needle and biopsied at
week 12
the cancer what you'd see is you see an
influx of t cells and other inflammatory
cells
and probably also tumor necrosis going
on there
so it gives the appearance as if the
tumor is growing when it actually
is going through inflammation and dying
so this is a landmark study that
led to the fda approval of ipalumab or
anti-siplay4
in metastatic melanoma under y-axis is
overall survival
on the x-axis is time in months
and the ipalumab was compared to
the control group as a gp 100 vaccine
and you can see there are two ipalumab
groups one with ipolium monotherapy in
red
and the second one epileum plus gp100
vaccine
in blue both arms
actually improve median overall survival
but the other interesting thing that was
surprising is that there's a tail at the
end of curve
and that tail suggests that there's
durable responses here
in fact a retrospective analysis of
patients treated with
epileumab shows that this tale develops
around
three years at 36 months
and can go on to approximately 10 years
we believe this represents durable
responses and even curative ones
so this sort of changes how we think
about standard drug development
initially we always thought about it is
the drug improving
survival is it causing the curve to
shift to the right from the purple
to the blue bar but now with
immunotherapy
such as epileumab we're not just asking
the curve to shift to the right
we're also asking to raise the tail
because you can see
in the purple and blue bars with
eventual time
all the patients will succumb succumb to
the cancer and pass away
but with the immunotherapy anti-64 with
the tail raised
these are durable or even curative
responses that we're seeing
so these studies led science magazine
to consider cancer immunotherapy the
breakthrough of the year in 2013.
and since the discovery of ctla4 as an
immune checkpoint or a break
on t cells two other breaks were
discovered
pd1 and pdl1 and
and many others but these three have
cons are the ones that have been
targeted by pharmaceutical companies and
led to the fda approval
in multiple cancers listed here in blue
and underneath and bulleted under these
cancers are all the drugs that target
one of these three immune checkpoints
cta4
pd-1 and pdl-1
this led the nobel committee to award
the nobel prize
in 2018 to jim allison for his work on
c2a4
and tosuko hanzo for his work with pd1
so although targeting the brakes ctla4
and pd1 inhibit
or sorry targeting releases the breaks
off the t
cells they actually work mechanistically
in different ways and i want to point
them out here
so antiseptic 4 functions more with
signal two or the co-stimulatory pathway
cb28
whereas anti-pd1 works more in signal
one
which targets the t cell receptor
pathway
anti-suta four works on t cell priming
so that's the initiation of a t
cell response from it recognizing
antigen for the first time
whereas anti pd1 tends to work more in
the effector
phase or within the tumor
microenvironment itself where the t
cells are exhausted
because it works in priming antiseptic
four oscillators expands
coronal diversity which antipedia one
does not
anticipate four works primarily on cd4 t
cells whereas anti-p1
primarily on cdat cells
i'll show you examples of this later but
antiseptic 4 can convert a cold tumor a
cold tumor is one that has
a few t cells in it and it can convert
it into a hot tumor by moving more t
cells in
which antipedia one cannot do
and because antiseptic four tends to
work in the beginning of a t cell
response it
its responses clinically are often
slower
as opposed to a rapid response as you
can see with anti-pd1
because it's working at the level of the
tumor microenvironment
there are more toxicities seen with
anti-cetala4
and disease recurrence after a response
is rarer so you see more durable type
responses with anti-seizure 4
than you do with anti-pd1
so here's example of a melanoma patient
treated with an anti-pd1 or pdl1 agent
and so you can see the melanoma itself
on the patient
but right above it you see the tumor
microenvironment
and it's characterized with cd8
immunohistochemistry
there's a red line there as well and
that
above the red line represents the
the tumor margin and below it is where
the tumor
exists and you see a lot of cda t cells
uh right at the tumor margin and a few
cdat cells
within the tumor itself and this would
be considered an immunologically hot
tumor
and when you treat with anti-pd1 or pdl1
you see an
influx or increase in cda to
t cells right into the tumor and that's
associated with
improved clinical outcomes of the
patient's melanoma
now in a separate study they looked at
kidney cancer patients and here's an
example of a patient
where they're looking at transcriptional
levels
of genes associated with t cell
activation
or t-cell effector functions and
following treatment with anti-pd1 or
pdl-1
you can see an increase in these gene
expression levels
now here's an example of a cold melanoma
tumor which has
few cdat cells and following treatment
with antipedia one and pdl one
you see that there is no influx of cd8 t
cells so it's unable to convert this
cold tumor
into a hot one and as a result you can
see the melanoma progresses
or gets bigger in this patient and
here's an example of a transcriptional
profile of
a woman with breast cancer which also
considered
immunologically cold tumor and you can
see following treatment of the antipedia
one or pl1
none of the genes associated with t cell
activation or effective function have
increased
so do immune checkpoint therapies work
in prostate
cancer this was one of the first studies
there's a phase one study looking at
nivolumab or
anti-pd1 in a multiple different
malignancies and that 17 patients in
this study
had prostate cancer and there are no
objective responses meaning no
partial responses or clinical responses
seen radiographically
more recently a number of patients with
metastatic prostate cancer were
evaluated who were treated with
embryolismab
another anti-pd1 agent and you can see
the response rates were ranging from
three to six percent
of patients who actually uh received
that had a partial response or a
complete response
but in this bar graph here which
represents each bar represents
individual patient
you see that a subset of patients
actually did
have some durable responses so overall
it's a low response rate
but the few that do respond tend to have
durable responses
anti-cta4 epileumab has also been
tested in prostate cancer and two phase
three studies
here's the first one it's in the
pre-chemotherapy setting
and here epileum was directly compared
to placebo
and you can see there's an improvement
in progression-free survival
it was also tested in the post
chemotherapy setting in a phase three
study
and here if blue map was also compared
to placebo
but both the ipalumab group and the
placebo group
received radiation therapy to up to
three bone metastatic fields
so this is epileum plus radiation
therapy
versus placebo plus radiation therapy
and again you see
increased progression free survival
suggesting that there is activity of
epileum
however when we look at overall survival
in both the pre-chemotherapy
and the post-chemotherapy groups there
fails to be an
overall survival benefit
the one thing that i do want to point
out and i'm more obvious in the post
chemotherapy group
that there is a tail at the end of the
curve if you look at the red line
there is a tail there an updated
analysis
uh speaking uh with personal
communication with the
the authors of this um trial
state that there's still a tale five to
seven years out
so this is uh something where we're
seeing that
as an overall survival it doesn't help a
patient with prostate cancer
but there are a subset that benefits
so one of the questions our group had is
can we identify
these patients who benefit and can we
use immunological biomarkers to identify
them
so in order to do that we developed an
investigative initiated trial with 30
patients
all the patients had metastatic prostate
cancer
and we asked the patients to have their
primary prostate
or their metastatic prostate either
biopsied or resected
so that we had sufficient tissue for
whole exome sequencing
and and rna sequencing
so that we could identify potential
tumor mutations
at that point the patients were able to
receive four doses of hippolymp
at three milligrams per kilogram which
is the fda approved dose
and we collected peripheral blood at
each of these time points
here the clinical outcomes of the
patients looking at progression-free
survival in months
on the y-axis versus overall survival in
months in the
x-axis by doing this we were able to
stratify our patients into three groups
you notice a group in green
has prolonged progression-free survival
and prolonged overall survival
and a group in purple has a very short
progression-free survival of less than
six months and a short overall survival
of less than
12 months and so these are the two
groups and
also want to point out that many of the
patients in
the green group
which would which we call the favorable
group
are still alive today for our biomarker
analysis we actually compared
the green group which is the favorable
group versus the purple group the
unfavorable group
we looked at tumor mutational burden
across disease sites so looking at
primary prostate versus the metastatic
lymph node
and other sites of metastasis and we use
the frequency of non-synonymous
mutations
as a measure of tumor mutational burden
in this cohort of 30 patients
the median frequency of non-synonymous
mutations
was 76 this is in stark
contrast to the median that's been
observed and
published for metastatic melanoma and
non-small cell lung cancer
where the median is 200 both metastatic
melanoma
and non-small cell lung cancer are known
to be
highly immunoresponsive and tend to
respond well to immune checkpoint
therapies
so you can see on the graph to left
that there's no difference in tumor
mutational burden between primary and
metastatic sites
and surprisingly there was no difference
between the
patients who had favorable responses
versus unfavorable responses
i say surprisingly because in melanoma
and non-small cell lung cancer
higher tumor mutational burden is
associated with
higher response rates to immune
checkpoint therapies
we looked at peripheral t cell responses
to tumor associated antigens such as
prostatic
specific membrane antigen or psma
and we're using an ellie spot assay here
where we're counting
the number of t cells producing
interferon gamma
a th1 cytokine and you can see at
baseline
there's very few ellie spot t cells or
t cells producing interference gamma but
after four doses
you can see a significant increase
that's also seen with the tumor
associated antigen
prostatic acid phosphatase or pap i want
to point out if you look very closely
you can see the the post
epileum dose number four time point is
38 weeks
after that dose so these are durable
peripheral t-cell responses we're seeing
here's example patient number seven who
has a low tumor mutational burden you
can see the number of non-synonymous
mutations
in this patient is 13. remember the
median for this group
is 76 and the median for
melanoma and lung cancer is
approximately 200.
so here's a patient with low tumor
mutational burden
when we use the rna-seq data to see how
many of these mutations were expressed
eight were expressed and we used an
ellie spot analysis
to detect potential neo antigens an
example of one
this is rogue waning nucleotide exchange
factor 37
where the arginine is substituted for
tryptophan
on the left you see the raw early spot
data with the wild type protein you see
very few t cells responding to that wild
dot protein
but in the mu with immune protein you
can see a lot of t cells producing
interferon gamma
this is graphically represented in the
blue bar graph
and you can see at baseline the
new antigen is responses virtually
undetectable
but after four doses of epileum you see
a significant enhancement
now to determine whether or not cda t
cells or cd4 t cells are responsible
responsible for this
response we depleted either cd4 cells or
cd8 cells and when we deplete cd4 t
cells
we don't see a significant difference in
in um the number of ali spot t
cells but when we deplete cdat cells you
can see a significant
decrease suggesting that this is a class
1 restricted mhc class 1 restricted
neoantigen
we also had pre-treatment tissue in
which we did rna sequencing
and we did gene set enrichment analysis
and found that the interference gamma
response signature
was upregulated in the favorable cohort
as opposed to the unfavorable cohort
in addition we use uh t-cell signal or
sorry
immune signatures looking at various
immune subpopulations
within the tumor microenvironment
transcriptionally
and found that cytotoxic t cells and
memory t cell signatures were
upregulated
in the favorable versus unfavorable
cohort this is all
consistent with the fact that having
more t cells that
have a th1 phenotype or interferon gamma
and effector phenotype are associated
with favorable outcomes
and we confirm this at the protein level
looking by immunohistochemistry
and you'll see that there's more cd8 t
cells in the fabric group
and right next to the cd8 ihc is also
reenzyme b that is a marker of
t cell cytolytic activity
so inclusion for this part of talk low
tuning
tumor mutational burn tumors such as
prostate cancer
can have high density of t
effector cells or interferon gamma
signature within the tumor
microenvironment
it's unclear whether these can be used
as a biomarker to select for patients
who are most likely
to benefit from immune checkpoint
therapies but we are currently trying to
validate this in a larger cohort of
patients
on an international clinical trial
in addition we found that you can
actually detect
tumor neuroantigens in patients with low
tumor mutational burden
and we're able to confirm this in an end
silicon algorithm and that's important
because that means we can actually
develop
personalized new antigen vaccines for
patients
using an insulin algorithm and finally
we
showed in that implement enhanced
systemic
antigen-specific t-cell responses to not
only tumor-associated antigens
but also to cancer neoantigens
so what prevents anti-seize i4 from
being more effective
in prostate cancer and as i showed you
earlier
it did not lead to an overall survival
benefit
in two large phase three studies to
answer this question we looked at pre
and post
treatment tissue by immunohistochemistry
and you can see in the pre-treatment
tissue
prostate cancer is immunologically cold
with very few cd4
and cda t cells present by
immunohistochemistry
but following treatment with two doses
of epileumab
you can see a significant infiltration
of t cells
so here's an example where hippolymp
converts
a cold tumor into a hot tumor
and these t cells are actually activated
as they express
icos they have a memory phenotype as
they express cd45ro
and they have cytolytic activity as they
express granzyme b
so these t cells have a license to kill
but something's preventing it from
killing it
because if you look closely you'll see
that there's still adenocarcinoma
of the prostate still present in this
tumor micro environment
to determine what's preventing the t
cells from killing we looked at
match pre-imposed treatment tissue at
differentially expressed genes
and found 650 genes were
differentially regulated following
treatment with epileumab and
of these genes 41 were what we
considered immune related genes
we focused in on known immune
checkpoints
and what we found was at the
transcription level
both pdl1 and vista were up regulated
in the post-treatment tissue
we confirmed this by
immunohistochemistry where you can see
pdl1 expression
both on immune cells as well as the
tumor cells
and you can see vista expression on the
immune cells itself
we then use multiplex immunofluorescence
to understand
which immune cells are actually
expressing pdl1
and to also determine who's expressing
more the tumor cells itself or the
immune cells
so you can see aqua represents the tumor
cells pdl1 represented by white color
cd4 in green cd8 in red
and cd68 denoting a macrophage
population or myeloid population
is in yellow and here's a graphical
representation
showing that following treatment of the
blue map you see an upregulation
on cd8t cells and cd68 macrophages
as well as on the tumor epithelial cells
where you see very little up regulation
on cd4 t
cells and you can see that the
the frequency is equal
between the cdat cells cd68 macrophages
and the tumor cells
we also looked at vista expression on
and pdl1 expression on a cd68
macrophages
and here again we use multiplex
immunofluorescence and what we
identified was three different
populations
macrophages that express pdl1 alone
macrophages express
vista alone in yellow sorry in white
vista's in white
pdl1 is in purple and cd68 again is in
yellow
and then we also found macrophages that
express both vista
and pdl one that's graphically shown
here on the right side and what you see
is that there are very few
macrophages that express both vista and
pdl one
suggesting their their expression
pattern is mutually exclusive
and maybe there's different ways in
which they function as
immune checkpoints in inhibiting t cell
responses
but you can see that all three
populations are upregulated following
treatment
with a balloon map
so we did an x-vivo t-cell
analysis looking at interfering gamma
production
when t cells exposed to mitogen likes
anti-cd3 and you can see there's a
significant upregulation of interference
gamma
but in the presence of the immune
checkpoint pdl1 there's a
slight reduction in interferon gamma
production
in the presence of vista inhibition
there's a significant
reduction in interference gamma and when
you inhibit
both vista and pdl-1 function
or when you uh when you inhibit t cells
with uh
vista and pbl1 you see an additive
effect
in reduction of interference gamma and
this also holds true for another th one
cytokine
tumor necrosis uh factor out
uh factor alpha
so the the data here suggests that
vista and pdl1 function to inhibit t
cell using different mechanisms
we then looked at what happens in
patients treated with ipolium
in prostate cancer versus melanoma in
the context
of these pdl one expressing macrophages
and we can see that ipalumab in red
enhances the frequency of these
macrophages
more so in prostate cancer than it does
in melanoma
and the same holds true for vista
expressing macrophages
it seems to increase more in prostate
cancer than in melanoma
we then did some transcriptional
analysis and found that
the the that these
macrophages actually are an m2 phenotype
they don't express a lot of iron they
express a lot of arginase
so they're quite immunosuppressive
we then turn to a mouse model of
prostate cancer and targeted both
uh ct4 and pd1 and
found that when you target both in a
murine model of prostate cancer
you improve survival as opposed to
monotherapies
alone so this concludes
this part of talk the conclusion is
iplumlab
can upregulate immune checkpoints p1 and
vista
in the
to work appear to work in different
mechanisms
they are definitely expressed on
macrophages to and and these are
on m2 type macrophages to suppress t
cell functions
and then finally targeting both the c2a4
and pd1 checkpoints
improved outcomes in a pre-clinical
model of prostate cancer
the question is does it help in patients
so to answer that question we led and
we designed a multi-center international
trial with 90 patients
with prostate cancer and they were
divided into
two cores of patients cohort one was a
pre-chemotherapy cohort
and cohort two is a post-chemotherapy
cohort
and patients were treated with the
combination of nivolumab which is anti
pd1
plus ipalumab antisepta4 using the
fda approved dosing regimen for
metastatic melanoma
here we see and i'm just focusing on the
details with the
red uh uh
red uh rectangular
highlights showing that most patients
whether it was the pre-chemotherapy
cohort or post chemotherapy court
did not receive all four doses of the
combination
and the major reason for that if you
look below
is because 50 approximately 50 percent
in
in the pre-chemotherapy court and forty
four percent in the
post-chemotherapy cohort actually had to
discontinue due to drug toxicity
so there was a safety issue with this
combination
but despite having these safety issues
where patients didn't receive all four
doses of the combination
you we saw dramatic clinical responses
in a subset of patients
in approximately 25 percent in
pre-chemotherapy court and approximately
10
in the post chemotherapy cohort these
are
partial responses and complete responses
so a total 11 patients
out of the 62 who had measurable disease
now i'm going to show you in the next
slide each of these 11 patients
each bar represents
one of these 11 patients and you can see
that on the x-axis we have time in
months so
so you can see that many of these
responses are durable
in nature in fact two of these patients
are
ones that i treated at md anderson
cancer center
and this data lock happened a year and a
half ago
and these two patients of our are still
doing well with undetectable psa
and scan showing no evidence of disease
and they have been
off any other treatments these are
patients who had a life expectancy
of less than 6 to 12 months and are now
living
a full life without cancer
we looked at biomarkers associated with
with these durable responses and if you
can see on the left we looked at pdl-1
expression in the tumor
versus homogeneous recombination defects
or dna damage repair defects
and and with pdl-1 status or hrd or ddr
we do not see any associations
with durable responses but when we
looked at tumor mutational burden
in this case we were able to see
something that was associated which i'll
show you in the next slide
we divide the patients into high tumor
mutational burden versus low tumor
mutational burden
in this cohort of patients the median
tumor mutational burden was
74.5 based on the number of
non-synonymous
mutations and so this is very similar to
what i
said before in the other clinical trial
where the median was 76.
and so the high tumor mutational burden
or
patients who had greater than the median
and low is
less than the median and so when you
look at progression-free survival on the
y-axis versus time in months
on the x-axis you can see patients with
a high tumor mutational burden
were associated with improved outcomes
again this is consistent what we see in
metastatic melanoma
as well as non-small cell lung cancer
here's a raw data for each of the 11
patients who experienced a partial
response a complete response
and on the right column you see tumor
mutational burden
and you can see in blue number 20.
that is the patient with a low tumor
rotational burden
and all the red ones show the ones with
relatively high geometrical burden
i highlight or circle the ones in
with the black circle because if these
patients with prostate cancer
actually had melanoma or lung cancer
they would be considered
low tumor mutational burden the median
there is
greater than or equal to 200.
as i mentioned there was some safety
issues that we had to consider
but because of the efficacy that we saw
we expanded the
the phase two study to include
approximately
315 patients into
four arms arm one is
arm d1 and arm d2 are looking at
different
dosing and scheduling of the nivola
maple supermoon map
rmd1 using the renal cell dosing rmd2
using the non-small cell lung cancer
dosing
both are shown to be less toxic than the
melanoma dosing
arm d3 is a balloon monotherapy and rmd4
is the uh escapasy taxal chemotherapy
so in conclusion we find that
targeting both c34 and pd1 appears to
improve clinical outcomes in a subset of
patients
whether or not this is associated with
high median tumor mutational burden
needs to be determined in a larger
cohort of patients
we were exploring different dosing and
scheduling
regimens to try to mitigate the
toxicities and maximize on the efficacy
but clearly just targeting these two
immune checkpoints is not
the answer because there appears to be
other
primary and adaptive resistant
mechanisms contributing to why a greater
subset of patients are not responding to
this
approach we've also uh
embarked on a collaboration with the
parker institute of cancer immunotherapy
to see if we can use the combination of
targeting anti
pd-1 and anti-seize 4 with radiation
therapy
with the hopes of radiation therapy will
elicit more
new antigens that can be recognized by
by the t cells and then
while we're giving this regimen we will
develop
a neoantigen vaccine would take us
approximately 12 weeks
and once a vaccine is developed for each
patient because it's a personalized
vaccine
it will then be added to this regimen
so now i'm going to turn to the last
part of the talk what about the
immunosuppressive prostate tumor
microenvironment
so this is a meta-analysis done by susan
halby
and what she shows here looking at
approximately 10
000 patients with prostate cancer that
you can see the
frequency of the distribution of the
disease approximately 70 to 80 percent
of patients
have bone metastases either bone alone
or bone plus lymph node
and this is associated with poor
survival
compared to the lymph node only disease
we looked within the bone tumor
microenvironment
and we found that there are very few cd3
t
cells inside the bone tumor
microenvironment
and that's graphically shown on the
right and
each symbol represents an individual
patient in blue you see the normal bone
marrow
having a high cd3 density and in red
you see very few
t cells within the bone metastases we
also confirmed this in a murine model of
prostate cancer to the bone
the red bar shows you the tumor margin
so
the tumor is actually located beneath
the
red bar and you can see very few t-cells
present there so this recapitulates what
we see in our patients
and you can see the graphical
representation to the right
with each symbol representing an
individual mouse
we then turned to our patients data and
looked at
transcriptional uh up regulation of the
th1 phenotype
following treatment at balloon map and
we found that after
giving a balloon map in the primary
prostate tissue you do see an increase
in the th1
t cells however you fail to see this
in the prostate bone metastatic site and
the th1 phenotype is critical
for anti-tumor in anti-tumor
immunity that's regulated by indian
checkpoint therapies
we then turn to our mouse model and
found when we looked at the subcutaneous
tumor
again we can see this th1 upregulation
with immune checkpoint therapy
but we fail to see this in the bone
tumor microenvironment
in our mouse model we're able to use
each individual mouse as its
individual control so you can see that
on
the right tumor so the right
[Music]
bone has tumor whereas the left bone is
tumor free
and we can measure multiple cytokines uh
from this tumor microenvironment and we
found that there were elevated tgf beta1
levels
in the tumor-bearing bones and this is
consistent with what we see in our
patients so those with osseous or bone
metastases
have higher levels of tgf-beta1
we went back to our mouse model and we
targeted both cta4 and tgf beta
and compared it to monotherapies and
found that if you look at
week one there's no difference in um
in tumor growth but in week two
targeting both cta4 and tgf beta reduce
tumor growth rates
and the same holds for week three
we looked at th1 responses and found
that only the combination of targeting
c34 and tj beta
increases the th1 response whereas the
monotherapies don't
and this is associated with improved
survival
so immune checkpoint therapies have
limited efficacy
as monotherapies in patients with
prostate cancer
especially those with bone bone
metastases
and it appears that targeting both c34
and tgf beta
can improve outcomes in our marine miles
of prostate cancer
and this needs to now be validated in a
clinical trial
and this is a clinical trial that we're
in negotiations
with pharmaceutical companies and
developing
to confirm our preclinical findings
so the immunosuppressive prostate tumor
microenvironment is characterized by few
t
cells and enrichment of
immunosuppressive myeloid cells
as well as presence of immunosuppressive
cytokines
so moving forward we need to develop
rational sequential or combinatorial
strategies
to increase t cell infiltration deal
with
immune checkpoints that can be an
adaptive resistance modulate the
immunosuppressive cells
but there's other factors that i didn't
get a chance to explain today
such as metabolism hypoxia microbiome
and epigenetics
all these factors are being evaluated in
various clinical trials with the immune
checkpoint
therapies and finally we need to improve
patient selection
because of time i'm just going to skip
over the last two slides and go right to
acknowledgements
i'd like to thank our patients first and
foremost for their courage to go on
these studies
not only do they take the chance of
going on an experimental
trial but they also give the gift of
their
of their tissues so that we can
biologically better understand
how the drugs affect them in addition uh
i have to acknowledge the geo medical
oncology group including jj gao
who helped with the uh vista store and
pdl one story
and chi ping zhao for the tgf beta story
uh the checkmate 650 investigators
and then special thanks to my mentors
jim allison and pam sharma
and then andy futrill for the neoantigen
work
uh brian shape and urology to help and
and patricia truncosa
in pathology with their help in uh in
obtaining
primary prostate tissues and finally
my funding sources thank you
ready for questions
and thank you so much dr cebudi for that
outstanding presentation
and we will now move to the q a portion
of this presentation as a reminder
please submit your questions
via the q and a box so let's take a look
um dr cebudy at our first questions
coming in we have quite a few
um audience members and quite a few
questions already
in the box ready to be answered so let's
look at our first
and questions coming in what is the role
of the eosinophilus
i apologize neutrophilus and mast cells
on tumor cells
that's a great question so it's
unclear at this point in preclinical
models
neutrophils tend to um
to enhance or i should say neutrophils
tend to be more immunosuppressive
and so targeting neutrophils is
something that
us and other groups are trying to
consider to get rid of
now in regards to eosinophils and mast
cells
they've been used as biomarkers
especially with drugs like cypillusal t
which is a
immunotherapy and
they've been shown to be biomarkers of
response
but their roles in anti-tumor immunity
it's still
unclear
thank you for that our next question
other than what you
have shown what do you think are the
most exciting
immunotherapy combinations being in
prostate cancer
yeah so at asco it was shown that the
combination of a tyrosine kinase
inhibitor
cabozantinib plus the immune checkpoint
pd1 or targeting pd-1
led to significant clinical responses
and approximately
33 percent of the patients there's a lot
of
pre-clinical data showing that cabo's
anthem there's a nature paper by rhonda
pina's group in 2017
which in the campus and it can actually
deplete the myeloid derived suppressor
cells
and gary galax group in a different
paper showed that cabozen it can also
affect
the neo angiogenesis and so
kabul's anthony is a tki or trines
kinase inhibitor that
affects many aspects of the tumor
microenvironment including the tumor
cells and then
combining that with immune checkpoint
therapies it appears to be pretty
exciting
thank you for that and would it be
would you be able to um would vaccines
offer a long-term protection against
cancer
yeah we do believe vaccines can do that
and they have done it in a subset of
patients in clinical trials
the issue is that many of the vaccines
are designed to just
target one tumor antigen or tumor
associated antigen
and many times the cancer cells will
down
regulate that protein so that the
vaccine will be
less effective so we think that
the successful vaccines will be ones
that
target multiple proteins expressed on
the
prostate cancer in addition you need
vaccines
that can also cause antigen spread
and then finally we believe that new
antigen vaccines may be the answer to
this in the future
thank you for that dr booty and i also
want to thank our audience members for
these great questions
coming in um the next question
is it is it because of the nature of the
bone
that cbc3 cells cannot enter
yeah no it's actually not that because
the bone marrow is a place where
a lot of t cells develop so
or so so b cells for sure
develop in the bone marrow t-cells
developing of thymus but then they go
there
and and they sort of hang out so it's a
what we call a secondary lymphoid organ
and so the normal bone marrow is
chock full of t cells but there's
something that's preventing
the t cells from entering the cancer
itself
whether that's neutrophils or myeloid
cells or some sort of
chemokine gradient we don't know what
that is at this point
other groups have shown in other cancers
that p10 deficiency can cause this
as well as the wind pathway can also
cause it so we're looking to see if
that's the same in prostate cancer
thank you our next audience member first
says very clear and thank you for this
interesting talk
it's a two-part question have you tried
if rt
in combination by using different
schedules
with these icis that can improve the
outcomes in patients
that's the first part of the question
and by targeting other immune
um modulatory agents
if not what would you expect
yeah so i think radiation therapy
belongs in in this
uh multidisciplinary approach that we
have
towards overcoming the immunopress
suppressive prostate tumor
microenvironment but
how to do that is challenging because
there's different types of radiation
there's stereotactic
there's standard radiation
and then there's also so different doses
are important and you give different
doses to
different tissues because the bone and
prostate you can't give the same
amount of dosing and what we need more
trials are
is looking at how the different dosing
and the different
organ sites affect the immune
microenvironment
for example there's some data coming out
of lung cancer that if you go
with too high dose of radiation you kill
a lot of the immune cells
so a lower dose can be beneficial but we
really need to dissect this out
both in our preclinical models as well
as in our patients
before we can rationally start combining
them
with immunotherapies can you repeat the
second question again please absolutely
and by targeting other immune
modulatory agents um
and then it just says if not what would
you expect
yeah we definitely want to target
multiple immunothera
modulatory agents and it doesn't have to
just be immune checkpoints
it can be cytokines or other cellular
populations like regulatory t cells
the issue is when you do it concurrently
we have to
watch out for toxicities so one of the
things we're doing with the parker
institute of cancer immunotherapy
is we're trying to do biomarker rich
trials where we're doing
multiple combinations but in sequence
and so for example
one of the ideas that we're playing
around with is maybe we start off with a
vaccine to drive t
cells into the cancer and then
thinking about the adaptive resistant
mechanisms then come into the immune
checkpoint therapy
and then understand that myeloid cells
will also
be upregulated maybe choosing a cytokine
that chuck drake is working on
anti-il-18 for example to target the
myeloid population
thank you dr sebuti and we have time for
one more
question and then i just want to remind
our audience members any questions not
answered today will be
answered via email by dr cebudi
in the bone model for prostate cancer
was self-feeding from one bone to the
other a phenomenon
that you had considered or were
concerned about
repeat that again self-feeding you said
is in the bone model of prostate cancer
was
self-seeding from one bone to the other
if a phenomenon
that is considered or we're concerned
about yeah
so in the mouse model of prostate cancer
we actually did not we do not see
self-seeding
but it has been described
in in patients when they did
a phylogenetic tree in a warm autopsy
study seeing where
different metastases were coming from so
you can see
it going from one bone metastasis to
another so that that that phenomenon
has been seen dr cebudy
thank you for your important research
and your presentation today
and thank you audience for your
outstanding questions as a final
reminder
any questions that were submitted and
not answered today by our speaker
they will be addressed via email and
this presentation will be available
on demand and viewed until december of
2020 so please share it with a colleague
who might have missed today's exciting
topic
thank you again for your participation
until next time
have a great day bye thank you